so
I am going to now take.
this formula
and
plotted it put it inside.
Wolfram Alpha
because I want to refer to two things you see here.
If I go into if I go back to the exercise.
It says in order for you to solve this problem.
In order for you to know.
if the
random variable the standard the standardized normal variable
this Z
variable
will fall into
that range where you have 2.9.31. You would
have to use the lookup table for the Z score.
It looks like this you may have you will see
this in different textbooks.
Okay, I'm going to show you.
How what I will show you how one of these values is.
Like how you calculate one of these values and why you
would use a table instead of trying to calculate yourself?
Okay.
So let me go back to yes
this formula.
And here's how it works.
I'm going to copy.
this code
let's bring it into word from Alpha.
Okay.
And let me come back to the previous exercise for a
moment.
and there will be complete this what I want to talk about is how
the five function
took
the standard deviation of 1
and arrived at this value how I took
the standard deviation of minus 1 or after this value?
So we take the difference and determine the probability.
Okay.
the probability that
the experiments of a random variable a standardized
random variable will fall.
between
One standard deviation left one standard deviation that write
that whole story is 0.6. And I want to show you how you calculate this
number. If you know how to calculate step even though it's
in the table
Well, then you would know how to calculate.
Or for example again. Let me
remind you. This is leading we are going to
What we're trying to do is understand everything we need.
So we can do.
hypothesis testing regression analysis and
then determine
if
we are doing our statistical study correctly
or not.
So we have to understand what every single character.
What every single function means?
before we can
recognize
How accurate we are inaccurate we are with our statistical
study.